siguen traumatizados por su terrible
experiencia a manos de los ocupantes
rusos que los detuvieron durante 10 días
en su gerción natal y los sometieron a
torturas abotonas porque
nos ataron no llevaron a gersona habían
otras 12 personas algunas de las cuales
llevaban un mes allí
me golpearon en los riñones me golpearon
en la cara hasta que me sangró la nariz
ya están a veces nos daban descargas
eléctricas unos amenazaban con armas
incluso nos amenazaron con hacernos
pasar por un campo de Minas
[Música]
que son carga con las cicatrices de este
régimen de terror una semana después de
su liberación por los militares
ucranianos este centro de detención es
uno de los 11 identificados por las
autoridades los detenidos aquí sufrieron
violencia a diario he visto personas
detenidas con los ojos vendados o con
bolsas en la cabeza los mantenían aquí
los interrogaban todo el mundo trataba
de soportarlo lo mejor que podía todo el
mundo intentaba esconderse las fuerzas
ucranianas dicen haber descubierto más
de 400 a 30 casos de crímenes de guerra
en la región más que en cualquier otra
parte del país durante los nueve meses
de guerra